[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mary kay cabot covers the browns a
writer for cleveland.com the plain
dealer and a browns analyst for wky
tv
mary kay how would you sum up the last
24 hours
uh well it's been really crazy but i
think when you trade for an odell
beckham jr you have to uh plan that you
might have a little bit of zaniness uh
with the program that comes along with
the immense talent that he is at times
but uh it's it's been
stressful on everyone it's been
difficult uh inside that building in
berea there there's been a basically a
firestorm going on in there and uh and
it just needs a resolution okay when is
that resolution going to happen
you know i think it might take a little
time but i do think that odell beckham
jr has played his last ball for the
cleveland bronze i really think the only
thing left to do is figure out some kind
of an exit plan whether that is a
settlement that requires some money
given back or whether it require you
know it takes an outright release
whatever it is i think it's over
was obj at the facility yesterday
no he was not he was told to stay home
yesterday and the same thing has
happened today
he really is no longer a part of the
team and again his agent is talking to
brown's gm andrew barry and they're
basically just trying to work out some
kind of an arrangement where he is no
longer playing football for the brass
how long has this been building
well you know i think he came into this
season really committed to helping this
team win and ready to go he he rehabbed
from the torn acl and he was a good
teammate and just the good citizen all
the way up i think uh pretty much until
he got one target against the steelers
in that 15 10 loss for six shards one
catch for six yards in a game in which
they scored 10 points and he was on the
field for 43 snaps so it wasn't like he
wasn't out there
so i think that was it i think his camp
basically just said forget it we're done
we've got to get you out of here and
that's what happened but i wonder and i
don't know if you can tell us does does
he think that baker mayfield is avoiding
him on purpose on the football field or
does he think baker mayfield is just
inept
well
i i think it's probably
uh a mixture of and i don't know if
odell per se feels this but i feel like
his sort of his camp his inner circle uh
believes obviously we know this from
what his dad posted uh that baker wasn't
going to odell at times when he was open
and i also think that they believe that
uh you know that odell would fare better
with a higher caliber quarterback
i'm wondering if you put this to a fan
vote do you want to resign baker
mayfield to a long-term contract a max
deal where you're going to pay him at
least 40 million
what do you think the cleveland fans
would vote
uh you know what i i think that the
cleveland fans are still for the most
part behind baker mayfield and uh and i
think that the browns still believe that
he is their quarterback of the future at
least that's the vibe i have been
getting over the past
month or so that they really still
believe in him and uh and feel like
there have been some extenuating
circumstances this season injuries
on the part of baker and those around
him do you believe that he's the future
uh you know what i i
i wonder sometimes if he is or not i'm
i'm not as convinced as i was maybe at
the end of 2018
but still here's the thing
the receiving core
hasn't really necessarily
done an amazing job this year i mean
odell has been a non-factor jarvis has
been out of the lineup most of the time
kareem hunt is gone
i'm not ready to pass any judgment on
baker mayfield this season until i can
see him out there with a full compliment
around him he hasn't had again kareem
hunt jarvis odell
not one game has he had that whole
offense around
how close did the browns come to trading
odell beckham at the trade deadline
i don't think they came really close
because you know he still has about
seven million dollars left that he's
owed this season and i just don't really
think anybody was willing to pick that
up or could pick that up there aren't
that many teams that have that kind of
cap space handicapped this team second
half of the season within their own
division as far as just making it to the
playoffs
well you know it's going to be really
tough because of what those cincinnati
bengals are doing and this game on
sunday is enormous and you can hear
kevin stevansky talking about it in
terms of we're desperate and our lives
depend on it
i i think the browns have got to use
this really as a rallying cry i think
it's time for baker mayfield to show who
he is and what he is as a leader and
really kind of lead this team to the
playoffs they can still do it uh they've
got five division games left you got the
ravens coming up twice here yes uh so
you know they have the opportunity to do
it but they're gonna have to dig deep
and somehow this team is gonna have to
really turn it around and find the
passing game that's basically
non-existent right now thank you mary
kay we appreciate your time as always
thanks for having me mary kay cabot the
uh brown's beat writer for cleveland.com
the plane dealer and a browns analyst
for
wkyc
tv